you have a pen
oh thanks
Casey
I guess we'll go ahead and get started
welcome everyone to our Thursday
conference and I'm delighted to
introduce our speaker who for those who
are de maiz old-timers Nocera well
because she actually previously worked
for the program she's currently
assistant director of the OHSU teaching
and learning center so they're the folks
that run Sakai our learning management
system and in a prior life when she
wasn't as such a high esteemed position
she was the mirror de maiz Sakai person
and so many of us worked with her for
quite a bit as we use Sakai to put our
courses online either our on-campus
courses or online courses and so Sarah
is gonna speak to us today about active
learning
you may some of you may question why are
we having a talk on teaching and well
one reason why is because she
volunteered to do it but I actually
think this is actually important because
probably all of you who are in who are
fellows so who are PhD students or
postdocs will probably do some amount of
teaching even if you end up in industry
you certainly if you end up in academia
so it's important to be exposed to
learning concepts and what we're gonna
hear about today is active learning and
and I guess Sarah would be remiss if she
hasn't already planned out our active
learning activities and I actually have
to say I try to make use of active
learning in the teaching that I do
obviously if you're in an online
asynchronous situation that's a little
more challenging but but certainly in
person as a way to engage the audience
and not just lecture at them for the
entire time so anyways um Sarah
earned her master's of Education from
Portland State in 2009 and has worked in
various roles at OHSU since then as an
instructional designer active learning
coach and has also trained faculty to
help write good multiple-choice
questions which on the clinical side
these days is an important thing so
she's going to present to us today her
talk entitled keeping active strategies
to foster active learning in the
classroom very flattering introduction
so as bill mentioned I'm Sarah Jacobs
and I actually was an instructional
designer with the d- program for five
years so I'm very familiar with the
content I would not say I could earn a
masters or PhD and anything in
informatics but at least I kind of have
a little bit of the vocabulary so we're
passing around a sign-in sheet and I've
also left some workshop evaluation seats
on the ends of each table which will
come to hopefully up again please don't
throw those out till the end unless you
really want to that's okay you will find
probably that I'm sort of weird and
energetic so just kind of go with it and
hopefully hopefully it's okay so today
we're gonna talk about active learning
and not only is this important in
teaching but it's also important in
presenting so everyone probably in this
room is going to do a presentation even
if you don't do some sort of formal
teaching so this active learning applies
to all learners whether it's formal or
informal whether you're speaking to the
public or you're just teaching a class
and so today we're gonna talk about some
main concerns you may have with active
learning and also we'll talk about
hopefully I'll give you some ideas about
how active learning can improve teaching
or improve instruction and you should be
able to identify at least two rings
then we're gonna talk about how active
learning can improve knowledge retention
and learner satisfaction with any
presentation that you give and hopefully
you'll choose a strategy you'd be
willing to try and your next
presentation and identify that strategy
and discuss with your peers find out how
you might address some of those concerns
so first of all so this is truly active
I'm gonna have you write something on
these brightly colored sticky notes and
get up and stick them on the board up
there so basically what you're gonna do
I wish I'd worn pants so I could attach
this to my something what you're gonna
do is you're gonna identify any barriers
concerns or fears you have about active
learning you're gonna stick them on that
whiteboard up there and I will pass them
out sticky notes
Oh however many fears you have maybe
just keep it to active learning fear or
concern who doesn't have that fear
though anyone need any extra speaking of
thank you okay well what you're gonna do
is write it on the sticking out and
stick it on that board up there and oh
sorry
and I guess if anyone's online and
watching this little streaming it's
gotta think of any barriers or fears you
might have to trying active learning and
a teaching situation and maybe write it
down because we're gonna come back to it
either one so yeah if you have any
barriers like my students aren't gonna
like it for example might be one nothing
you should have that beer just say thank
you one that you have
okay you're ready to stick it on the
board okay you can get us I don't bite
let me know you can't get out
thank you
oh man lots of fears lots of scared
people I'm hoping they are sure
okay great thank you
all right let's see I'm trying to
summarize but maybe I shouldn't because
there are quite a few different ones but
there is a theme of lack of audience
comfort engagement or students are
easily distracted
I assume that's for students not the
teacher but could be either way there's
time time to develop it what time to
implement or both oh okay cool there's a
concern about learning styles not
everyone learns the same way that's a
good one
public speaking that's that's a tough
one
I'm not gonna cover that today Oh
welcome takes too long oh that's a good
one I won't have time to fit in the
content cool there's a sign-in sheet you
a few catch it somewhere floating around
the room okay great so we have a couple
of themes here um so we're gonna hold
that thought cuz we'll come back to that
but those are some things I just wanted
to kind of let's sort of exercise our
fears and get them out and then we'll
talk about how to address them kind of
closer to the end but one thing I want
you to imagine is how do you think
people learn so if we're looking at and
I apologize this is not in a 60 minute
interval which is normally helmut long a
teaching session is like this one but
normally how where do you think learners
retain the most knowledge in terms of a
40-minute session so is it high or low
in the beginning middle and end of a
session what do you think about that so
this is the let's say you give a test
either immediately afterwards or two
weeks later the information presented at
what point during
a session that's 40 minutes long will
have the highest retention or the lowest
retention okay so so here are some
actual responses I've gotten before from
people which one do you think is correct
okay which one is the orange one for
those of us colorblind people bottom
right okay
note to self change that color okay so
how many people think bottoms right how
many people think a different one or
something else okay does anyone want to
share what they might what they think
the curve might look like okay so
they're green okay the reverse of the
yellow so it starts high in this kind of
dropped off after there okay any other
thoughts on this okay oops degree of
retention yeah all right I gave away the
answer okay so there's a ton of research
out there that shows that this is kind
of more of the model of how people how
well people retain information when it's
presented during 40-minute session now
dr. Sousa is kind of tough did a
meta-analysis and sort of I guess
coalesced the information into something
he called primetime so in the first ten
five ten minutes is the highest degree
of retention throughout an entire
presentation so that's what he called
primetime one and that's when you want
to really present the meat of what
you're presenting so or the most
difficult concepts how many of us
structure our content that way okay
maybe some of us in the know I don't
know about you but when I used to teach
middle school and actually college isn't
that much difference in middle school
I used to spend the first couple minutes
taking attendance making sure everyone
was comfortable getting people to sign
into the worksheet or to the sign-in
sheet and now I've already wasted my
time when the learners are like ready to
go and our little sponges or large
funders whatever um okay so then sue
says sort of postulates which this has
all been very well documented that it
this is what's happening that it drops
off around twenty minutes to the lowest
it's ever gonna get and that's called
downtime and then if there's a spike at
the end what the psychological reason
for that spike is is a little unsure is
it oh I was just facing off now I have
to pay attention it's almost over
maybe or just like oh I'm done looking
at Facebook now I'm gonna go for
Instagram or Twitter or whatever when I
go back and start paying attention you
not sure um that's unclear so what Susa
suggests is do a really succinct intro
in that first five minutes and then jump
right into the hard stuff and then as
attentions begin to taper off do an
activity of some sort where they're
actually applying that knowledge and
then make sure during that prime time -
they're doing some sort of closure that
summarizes and hopefully it's a closure
activity so that the person or the
people are actually doing what they just
learned about or at least practicing a
little bit there any questions about
that yeah
okay good question so the question was
this is for a 40 minute interval and
that's what was studied in most classes
and I think that's because this was
studied in k-12 and then sort of applied
later to adult learning where periods in
a high school for example are about 4045
minutes but they did a study where they
they did they didn't do 60 but they did
120 it had 80 120 and 180 I think and
what they found was that when you scale
it out you expand the time all that
really happens is frankly I wanted to
sort of get a little bit longer but
downtown just expands a lot yeah exactly
that's right
cool thanks that's a great scientific
explanation yeah it is this is all based
on the primacy recency effect so I don't
I don't jump into that usually because
some people are getting kind of bored
but um I think it's fascinating it's
what I love talking about but yes this
is a very distilled easy to understand
way to describe this so um I want to
just talk a little bit about closure and
wrapping up I just want you to imagine
if you have a bunch of books on the left
or the right you got a pick them up and
take them away with you this kind of
talks about encoding or not um which
block which a bunch of books is easier
to pick up take away right the one let's
rap with the old belt strap this is why
you do a closure and this is how our
brains work if you have the learner well
I mean you could wrap it up yourself by
giving a summary of what we just talked
about but ideally you have the learner
summarize what they were and then that
encodes it in their memory in a in a
specific chunk that's recallable so
that's why we do a closure I sort of an
aside a little bit off timing wise but I
just wanted to mention that in case you
weren't sure what a closure is usually
you just have the student do something
where they wrap up what they've learned
in that last hour or two hours or five
hours yeah can I have a question I'm
also going to use the mic just I don't
know how many people are out there
listening but in case people aren't fit
maybe people can pick up the mic I
assume these studies are all done on
in-person lectures because you know
another common way of lecturing these
days what we do in this program is
people listen asynchronously they can
start it and stop it and is there any
data on that or is that just too new
because I mean theoretically if someone
gets to a point that oh I should've been
paying attention there they can just
back it up and listen to it again yeah
there is there is data on
online lectures to the the best practice
really is to chunk it into 10 to
15-minute chunks even though students
can go back in and rewind and re-watch
just make things kind of in little
nuggets of easily digestible information
that's kind of how our brains work these
days with all of the media that we
consume so this is definitely only for
in-person presentations this applies for
an in-person presentation any other
question okay so there are a couple
other reasons to do active learning in
your classroom beside the big pillar at
the bottom it increases knowledge
retention it also increases student
learning performance so whether they
look how they learn more effectively so
students learn more effectively when
active learning is done and that's a
little bit different than knowledge
retention and also students and teachers
report higher satisfaction I want you to
think about when you're presenting a
lecture and you're talking for 60
minutes how exhausting that is when
teachers even those that don't want to
do it often when they switch it up and
they have students doing some of the
talking and working together they report
higher satisfaction with their teaching
because they are not as exhausted and
they really feel like they understand
whether the students are getting it or
not and it can also create a sense of
learning community especially in a very
large lecture hall which isn't really
the case in many programs here at OHSU
okay so now we're gonna get back to
those fears so I anticipated what you
might say and came up with we're gonna
talk about the three kind of major
concepts that came up on the board
I've talked to people enough that I know
what comes up I know what they're scared
of I know what the barriers are so the
first one is I can't cover all the
content and several of you wrote that so
that is a serious but that's something
that I hear all the time from
instructors from students if I take time
to do active learning I don't have time
to cover this piece of the content
so what I want you to do we're going to
try an active learning method called the
silent Socratic dialogue so for this
particular activity you have to be
partnered up and what we're gonna do is
we're going to give you time to
individual writing and basically you're
gonna answer the question why do you
feel like you must cover all the content
in the presentation so you're gonna have
two minutes to write what you think the
answer might be and then you're gonna
swap papers so let me know if you need
some paper feel free they'll use the
back of the worksheet if you are the
evaluation if you want to make sure you
have a partner so this is a I know
you're all getting organized this is a
silent activity you
there's no speaking at all once you've
organized yourself you're gonna write
down your response you're in a swap and
you're gonna give each other a genuine
question based on what the first person
wrote and then you're gonna swap again
and then that person you're gonna
respond to each other's questions and
I'm gonna tiny
maybe well there's a spelling error on
my slide maybe just either you can
imagine why someone might think that or
you can yeah yeah that works
okay we'll write about that then
does anyone not have a partner just walk
with you can do it as threes but it's up
there you go okay so swap now you have
one minute to respond to the person with
a question that has to do with what they
just wrote
Oh
we'll talk about it later quiet time now
right a genuine question for the person
on the paper yeah so you're writing your
question
okay so it should be quiet we should be
writing questions to our partners oh she
can't read you got it okay
okay how many people need a little bit
more time to think of a question for
their partner okay there give you
another minute
I'm giving everybody a little minute
another minute on the second step
okay if you are ready slot papers back
to the originals so the person should
have their original paper if you're in
freeze and you should answer the
question
to run out of paper okay
okay how how you feeling ever you had a
chance to respond to the question how
many people need a little bit more time
okay let's give you ten seconds
okay so normally we would have the
second to read the response but I think
it's time to debrief because I some of
you were already starting to talk to
each other so that's a good sign that
means there's some sort of debate or
curiosity that was piqued okay
so does anyone want to talk about what
one of the conversations the silent
conversations that happen so you want to
have any have anything they want to
share about that can everybody hear me
okay yeah this is probably as far as
close as I can get sure I'm just worried
about my voice all right so the
curiously will come up in both of our
conversations in terms of the questions
was really about how do you prioritize
content and order content in a way to
basically focus on what you need to
cover and what the audience needs to
know or can know okay
anyone else want to share something that
came up or even something that was funny
or didn't didn't work about the activity
okay I would just say that legible
handwriting is important slash also
having a writing utensil both of those
we're issues and my reason okay like
that so being prepared I guess for
whatever the active learning activity is
could be challenging okay I do this
activity with doctors a lot so um they
somehow could read each other's
handwriting but nobody else can read
okay thankfully so one of our
conversations the like issue of like
what do you if you do run out of time
which is like very plausible impossible
like the idea that then your learner's
are like spending more time outside of
class and like doing learning on their
own and maybe not Z and seeing it for
the first time on their own and how like
it's usually like more ideal for one
someone see maybe more ideal for someone
when they're seeing stuff for the first
time to have sort of that like
face-to-face capacity to ask questions
etc but that like there's also the
positive that you're like inspiring
people to like actually do more learning
on their own and like really that's
actually good too so yeah okay so the
concern really is kind of learners are
alone when they're experiencing content
for the first time if you run out of
time
okay anything else that came up I mean
presumably what you're doing in class to
communicate that information is an
activity that has value and if your
model for dealing with the rest of the
content is learning on your own you're
basically saying that what you're doing
in class doesn't have that value or can
be ignored for the rest of the content
that you're unable to get to in class
there's kind of self-defeating came up
in our conversation was how well can you
count on your learner's to learn things
independently and how well are they
supported in terms of what resources
they're able to access how do they know
what to learn independently and how do
you kind of flip them on the right track
preparation what was the first thing the
value in class time is a concern or
disincentivizing attended not that so
much sure your devalue your I you are
either devaluing the content you don't
include in class or you are devaluing
the activity of active learning in class
if apparently it's fine
that you don't cover half the material
and that material is expected to be
learned just as well without what you do
in class in which case what are they
doing in class okay great um I found
myself wanting to speak and have a
conversation with my discussion partner
and and so I don't know if there's like
a meta agenda here in this activity but
I certainly felt that this format was
difficult for exchanging and it didn't
feel very Socratic to me because I had
many more questions than I could write
in those in that little bit of time and
so maybe that underlines the importance
of direct interaction instead of instead
of learning by writing but I don't know
yeah so I know I think Shoshanna has
come and presented to you about
about learning styles and this
particular activity is better for
students who don't like speaking so
that's kind of there is a little bit of
a meta agenda here and for some people
this is a very engaging way to learn I
personally learned better by just
talking a lot that's why I'm up here
presenting right but I it's this is a
really great way to engage quiet
students which there are a lot of them
so another way and a lot of you have
done this is is by doing online learning
quiet students tend towards a more
online learning because of that but if
you're trying to engage students in the
classroom in a live class or in a
face-to-face this is one method for
engaging those students who don't often
offer up their opinion yeah one other
advantage on the other end of that
extreme is if you have very enthusiastic
communicators if there's topic that
people are very interested in I've had
many very rewarding conversations and
benefits on either side but having a
real in person conversation and everyone
is inspired by the first half of their
Clause to comment on something else
those can occasionally get to very
productive places but it's also good to
have a venue where you have to finish
the thought that you wanted to
communicate and then presented in an
orderly way sometimes things can veer
off a little yeah true and actually this
is the abridged version of this I would
say if you do this really successfully
in a really deep dive into the material
and people's opinions or thoughts or
feelings about something you probably
want to give it a half-an-hour we don't
have a half an hour so I Bridge fit
about 10-15 minutes but but that might
address some of the issues and you can
have them swap back and forth as many
times as you want and even give them
more time to so they can write more
questions and respond more okay so we
have a couple of things we probably need
to address maybe not so much legible
handwriting but maybe in the future if
you use this method and then when I use
this method I will tell people to write
legibly this if someone's gonna read it
but running out of time is that's a huge
that's a huge concern
and and also there's so much content to
cover how do you prioritize that that's
a huge concern and we'll talk about that
a little bit later but yeah we'll talk
about that a little bit later we're
going to go on to the next most common
fear and at the end we'll kind of
brainstorm ways and we'll have a
discussion about ways we can address
some of these bigger bigger issues so
another one is learners don't like
active learning or they don't like
working as a team but I've heard this
one so many times and actually if you
look at course evaluations that are way
too few people who do active learning
get lower marks sometimes sometimes not
all the time they do it well it's
usually pretty good so that this is
incentivizes instructors to wanting to
try it right so how do you how do you
address this so learners don't like to
do it well they don't like to do it if
it's not well organized that's that's
really gonna take away not that they
don't that learners don't like to aren't
actively I'm sure you don't tell me that
yeah absolutely
if the group that if it the norm does
not feel like it's safe to contribute
then it's like very it's going to be
very hard to get people to talk
absolutely yeah and I used to observe
medical school lectures for a living I
did that for three years so forty hours
a week of observation teaching
observations what I found was medical
students are often very scared to be
wrong and so they won't participate in
active learning so there are methods to
kind of addressing that one is - I got
two innocent one is to make sure that
any any active learning that's done is
anonymous or quiet like the silent
Socratic dialogues tent students tend to
feel a little bit more safe they usually
pick a partner they feel safe with
and also using an online polling system
where the responses are not assigned to
a particular person that is a really
great way to engage people also you
really need to talk about safety and
establish norms in your classroom I
didn't do that today that's a safe place
right but seriously that's something
that you need to address especially when
you're teaching a class by yourself
or where you're going to experience the
same learners over and over again yeah
part of that function is actually
cultural it depends on the social
network or group of those students that
you're referring to so in the context of
medical students oftentimes depending on
the program there's this cultural
expectation of competition which means
that if they're learning in a group that
doesn't help one of them to get an
advantage so there's the subconscious
priming due to the culture of
competition with respect to med students
that promotes things like the solutions
are your suggestions such as an
organization yeah yeah dentistry too
tends to be very competitive I don't
know about you guys you seem pretty cool
it's not that being competitive isn't
cool okay so one way you can do this so
if people are feeling like I'm so tired
of think pair share which I've heard a
million times before because it's really
easy to implement so instructors use it
that particular method um one thing that
I've had people do really successfully
to promote that community and group work
is fill out a graphic organizer so you'd
either have a blank outline of a lecture
so with maybe slide titles or just main
takeaways and then you have students
kind of try and fill out what they've
what they're listening to and then every
once in a while you have them kind of
work as a table group and compare and
make sure everybody's on the same page
that's one way to kind of get people
talking but not really stress them out
right and it also so Shauna wanted me to
say this we did promotes active studying
because you take away a study guide from
that actual talk right so the learner
has a take away
so we're gonna do kind of a very tiny
version of this I'm gonna pass out a
handout that has I think it has 43 but
it might have 37 or it might be a
completely different number of active
learning strategies that you can try and
what you're gonna do is talk with your
table group or with a partner about
which one of these you might be willing
to try
there any extra pay I'll find one for
you
are there any extra as teachers what are
you willing to try which strategy would
you will it be willing to implement in
your next presentation and I apologize
for those of you who are online because
I don't have the handout for you
these are listed in alphabetical order
which is probably not very helpful for
you but may help you find them later
please just raise your hand to if you
have any questions about something you
see on the sheet
okay looks like most of you read through
most of them now feel free just talk
with your neighbor which one would you
be willing to try as a teacher
okay I see people are starting to get
into larger and larger groups and are
asking some questions like how does this
one work so let's draw it back in if
anyone have a question first of all
about how one of these methods might
work something you're curious about that
you're not sure how you do that okay I'm
gonna put someone on the spot I heard
something about mind mapping and how you
would do that in a large classroom so
I've seen this done in medical school
and what they do is they have the
students all working on an interactive
mind map together while the lecture is
happening so and I use this thing called
bubble bu bbl I think it's online and so
they're all kind of making their own
mind maps those I know Shoshana probably
talked about mind mapping for some
people this is like I don't want to do
that at all
that's me and for some people who are
very graphically organized this is like
this is like their dream activity right
so all you really have to do as an
instructor to set that up is give them a
platform to do it or kind of show them
what they need to do any other questions
about any of these methods
we were talking about like some of the
methods kind of single people out and
like methods where students are kind of
evaluating each other is kind of it I
think it can be very kind of encourage
the wrong kind of environment sometimes
where everyone's kind of being critical
of each other yes yeah you have to be
careful that you're not doing all these
kinds of activities yeah I'm gonna I'm
gonna push back a little bit on that I
think it really depends on what you're
teaching the audience the nature of it's
a Kathryn and I were talking about her
her course where where she's teaching
students how to do review and so having
students review a paper there is
teaching them how to do something that
they're gonna have to do later on and so
in those contexts that type of learning
is actually incredibly useful yeah so
that's in the context of a pick it's
usually in the context of the paper that
someone hasn't written Katherine right
or is it okay so but all described is
reviewed by one student not by the
entire class so there nobody's gonna
feel picked on by a thousand people
right no well there aren't I'm sorry
people in the class okay perfect yeah
the point I was trying to make is that
it really depends on what you're doing
your audience more than anything else on
the network of that audience how is that
how is that audience actually formed as
a cohesive group and what are the roles
that individual are playing within that
group and how can you leverage that in
order for people to teach themselves
yeah yeah you really need to know your
learners and the content really well to
pick the right activity for example you
would not want to do a polling audience
polling question on something that has
to do with ethics right that's just like
you know and I've seen that happen
before I'm like wow you can really make
a case for a lot of these answers so
maybe that's more of a discussion
question or or you could do it as a
silent Socratic dialogue because those
tend to
work better for the kind of like softer
I don't know whatever not soft sciences
but you know the more feelings effective
kind of kind of learning that happens in
school and and also like for example to
go back to the MD students they are
required to present and defend their
cases in front of a team so for them
they're used to being criticized
constantly and and so that activity
might work but it doesn't work with
everybody and you really need to be
sensitive to what you're teaching in the
audience that's a really great point
thank you
anyone else be willing to share
something they'd be willing to try like
one of the activities that maybe that
you've never heard of what sounds
interesting
we really liked the muddiest point um it
seemed like it was it wouldn't take up
too much time but it would kind of get
to understanding what we know what maybe
needs to be reviewed the most our
students and like maybe you can't answer
the most confusing point for every
single student that maybe just find like
you know see if there's a theme going on
and see if you can try to figure out
like where to put more time yeah yeah
good okay yeah I use muddy as a plane a
lot because it's easy and it doesn't
take very much time and hey I'm doing
some active learning what in one minute
okay um anybody else want to share
the the one minute paper is interesting
you know although some of some of the
lectures we give our sort of complex you
know they build on things so I guess you
would have to kind of pick the
appropriate time and and you know and
then some of the ideas are you know
complex and not amenable to just putting
into a you know a simple paper then
there might be more need to develop some
detail yeah yeah was especially the
minute paper to I think people do it as
kind of a hey what are the main
takeaways from today's talk got a minute
to write it down I think that's a really
good way to use it
it's a great way to challenge if
somebody has an upcoming this is
actually better often in high school
that you have AP exams where somebody
has an upcoming times written exam so
for example for American history forcing
students to write women to papers after
every class will net them better scores
on their AP in the long run on the order
of most people in threes two fives cool
I've never heard of that example um
that's very interesting
okay so last one we're just gonna cover
quickly because I want to start getting
back to some of the barriers and and the
questions that came up so another one
was I don't have enough time to prepare
or I don't know what I'm doing so I'm
just gonna answer that one really
quickly we're not gonna really talk
about it but I would suggest to
look at the activities on the sheet that
are marked with a1 or a2 those are very
easy to do and then google the name of
it you'll find instructions on how to do
it and I hear a lot I don't have time in
my talk that came up before I don't have
time to cover all the content I don't
have time to do active learning and
cover everything that I want so it goes
back to that prior prioritizing content
so what did you what are your thoughts
on that how do you prioritize content
okay so does it contribute it for your
narrative uh-huh
talk too much anyways as it is but sorry
about that
um I normally adopt a couple of
different heuristics I think of I find
first of all it depends on the audience
so I think about first what is the
audience what is the audience capable of
learning because often especially in
Sciences we're dealing with topics that
are so complicated that we're often
coming from a place where we don't even
know where the gaps are yeah and so
really considering what does the
audience actually know and where do I
need to go from there what are the gaps
that allow them to get to a point where
they can learn things on their own
that's the point at which they need to
know so by balancing the heuristics
between what does the audience what can
the audience know and what does the
audience need to know you can assemble a
quick list of priorities for the content
which can then order your talk or
lecture or whatever you doing training
plan teaching plan yeah and and I'm just
gonna put out there the importance of
objectives having objectives for every
teaching the every teaching moment that
you do or every talk that you do you
need to think about what's the big
picture what's the big picture of what I
want the students to get today and then
really stick to those objectives within
difficult that's sometimes depending on
the audience yep yeah some people can
who are subject to my teaching can
decide whether or not they agree with
this but you know it's it's a challenge
because I really
most of stuff I teach about I'm pretty
interested and passionate about I think
it's important as a future informatician
to know but I also recognize you know
that there's just this huge sheer volume
so one of the things that that guides me
is how can I present the big picture of
you know like why are data standards
important and and you know kind of cover
that and a framework and then presumably
they will if they need to go fill in the
details so aiming to kind of present the
big picture on why this is important and
how the different pieces fit together
and then trying to force myself to keep
out some of the excessive detail that
will probably take too much time anyways
yeah
in light of that I think it's always
important to have a payoff like and I
think you should show the payoff first
like so for example if you're talking
about standards you should show an
example of why this is important and
then you can kind of delve into like the
other material yeah so it kind of
provide the example provides a framework
yeah for understanding the topic yeah
and honestly it's gonna engage it a
runner better anyway if they understand
why it's important I there's some sort
of there's kind of a debate about
whether you should tell a really
engaging story at the beginning of a
talk to get your learner's intrigued or
if you should really talk about the main
takeaways in a in a sort of dry
objective slide like I did there's a
debate about which one works better but
if you can do both that's that's amazing
and good luck what anybody else how do
you how do you think you could
prioritize content and this is something
that it's at the TLC we help instructors
with all the time they they come to us
and they say ah I have 12 credit hours I
have 47 hours of material how do we how
do I cut this and we can help them with
that
that usually involves rewriting
objectives so what are the objectives
from a week from the course from the the
module or the lecture anyone have other
thoughts what are the competencies what
do we want people to actually be able to
do other than to have this these Farex
sitting in their brain how do we want
them to apply the other mm-hmm
thinking about that in terms of
prioritizing things yeah so the the way
to cut content one way to cut content is
to flip your classroom now there are
there's a lot of problems with flipping
a classroom the biggest one really is
that you're actually going to require
students to do 17
more work than they would have a they
just come to lecture and then done the
homework so you have to be careful with
it but I think I would say you can trust
them to cover basic content but when it
comes to more complex things you really
want to make sure you're covering that
in class I'm not saying you can't
lecture lecture is fine just don't
lecture all the time right you need to
be doing they need to be doing something
with feedback from you I think that's
that's kind of a take away yeah flip is
a term that everybody might be familiar
with okay so sorry about that flipping
your classroom means you have students
watch lectures at home and then they
come and do something in class so they
have to come to class prepared and
having actually watch the lecture or
read the reading or whatever which is
problematic - yeah
I think it's also important to note
whether it be like a flipped classroom
or whether you're in class for like
teachers to also have an active voice I
don't know like the countless amounts of
classes where I've sat in a math class
for two hours and teachers have a
monotone voice because it's just a bunch
of you know numbers and letters and I'm
just sitting there like I can't focus
because your voice is just so disturbing
yeah so I think that's also very
important for like I don't know if
there's such thing as like active
teaching yes but that I think you need
to be aware of that too yeah and I mean
a few people mention presentation skills
in general we didn't talk about those at
all today we talked more about like kind
of how people learn but but that's
something that I think everyone should
do I had a student once recommend that I
take Toastmaster all regular
Toastmasters got a thick skin now but
back then it felt pretty good pretty
horrible and I didn't I'm here today so
if I lived but um yeah I think that we
need to be really convenient into how we
present and I think one of the most
enlightening experiences for me was to
record myself lecturing and then watch
it and critique myself super awful but
very informative and I changed my
practice so um yeah I think you're right
that's a good point you need to be maybe
conscious of how we're speaking and make
it interesting too math is really hard
anyway for a lot of us okay me um but
you know listening to monotone for two
hours that makes it even harder
so so the best statistics class I ever
took was at a community college and the
professor what she did was she actually
started by reviewing the history of
something so like Gauss and like the
development of the Gaussian distribution
and where that came from
what problem they were interested in why
they tried to solve it and then actually
you know how they tease it apart and
then develop the math around it and then
we'd apply it and it was like this
really nice like you know from the
theory and kind of the history in the
narrative that's really like you can
ground yourself in kind of get that yeah
to an actual practical application and
that full kind of walkthrough was really
yeah sounds great I wish I had taken a
statistics class okay I want to be
conscious every time it's 1234 so we're
not gonna do this think pair share we've
already kind of talked about what
sessions that are what activities we
might try but I just want to highlight
the main takeaways
we're in frying time too let's do this
um active learning hopefully you can
take you you see why active learning can
help a learner retain knowledge better
and also the importance of doing a
closure and then we didn't really talk
about this but if you're doing active
learning a lot then you probably don't
need to be worrying about prime time
tick one and two but if you're kind of
stuck in the lecture mode please present
new concepts first and difficult
concepts right away so that you're
getting the most brain capacity of your
learner and then hopefully you've
learned that active learning can be easy
and I would highly recommend 20-minute
chunking of a lecture so we have lots
and lots of other trainings you can find
online on our ode to thieves or on our
public website but please evaluate me
sorry I know you're going to lose your
writing on the back of the paper let me
know if that's a problem but leave your
evaluations up front here we use it to
improve our offerings and track our
impact across campus so I really
appreciate it
thank you